hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to share with you
the top five ways that i have lost money
in property if you're a property
investor or you're
going into property it is so easy to
lose money as well as make money so
i'm going to talk from experience right
now and tell you exactly how
i have lost out big time in property
over the last decade or so
firstly if you are new to the channel
please do subscribe and turn the
notification bell
on even if you're not new if you're not
subscribed you gotta subscribe
also the thumb the thumb needs to be
blue and it needs to be pointing up so
smash that like button and then we're
gonna get right into this so
first way i did a previous video about
this i talked about a property on durham
roads that absolutely sucked and
this was not necessarily my fault
sometimes
you're just going to be a little bit
unlucky you're going to have the odd
property
that needs a lot of maintenance there's
a few repairs
the tenants might not pay rent and when
you're doing your reporting you'll just
think man that property's really
not made much money you're going to have
the underperformers
the performers and the over-performing
properties and that's just
life so the first way that i've lost
money in property is just what happens
to
all property investors at some time
combined with market conditions
you see you can buy a house and it can
go up in value it can double in value in
the next five
six years and you're like yes i did so
well well not really you were kind of a
little bit
lucky now if you've got lots of
properties in lots of different areas
you're going to have some properties
like i've had that have shot up and made
loads of money you can have some they've
gone up a little bit and you can have
some have just sat there really stagnant
or even gone down that can happen that
is just
part and parcel of property investing
now if you only own one house in the
world
and that one house doesn't really do
much you have bad tenants
it goes down in value you might think
property investing is bad when you have
a lot of houses
it's just gonna happen to some of the
properties that you have got so that's
the first way that i've lost money in
property
the second way this is a little bit more
my fault
now i've got this thing where if i've
got money sat in the bank
especially a lot of money it makes me
feel really
really unhappy because i know that money
in the bank is shrinking down in value
i'm not getting any interest on it and
sometimes what i have done
is when i've got money in the bank i
don't like it that much
that i'll inv and you might be thinking
yeah whatever samuel no this is the
absolute god's honest truth
if i've got a lot of money sat in the
bank it makes me feel sad because i know
that that money should be working hard
for me i know it should be sat into a
good investment property so
my mistake has been this i've had money
in the bank
and i've not liked it and i've rushed
into buying something
which might not necessarily be the best
property and then what happens is
when something better comes along the
following week and you've just committed
to buy that one
now it's like oh well so why what i have
learned from this is it's best if you
can to always have
money in the bank not as an investment
you know
it's shrinking you know it's not giving
you any return on investment but have it
in the bank
so that you are ready when an
opportunity comes along it's
really really nice if you can just have
and depending on where you're at you
might want
five grand you might want a hundred
grand you might want a million pounds
depends on the size of your company but
if you've got a bit of money there
it just means that should a really juicy
opportunity come along
you're like i got the finance in place
that's a really powerful position now
you don't want to
do that so much so you don't buy
anything you want to be buying and
building
but have some cushion one of my mistakes
is i've invested all the money and it's
gone
and then an opportunity to come along
and i've had to miss it just because i
was too
quick to rinse my bank thirdly have i
lost money on property
i've lost money because i've bought them
and i've sold them cheaper than i bought
them
and this is really painful when it
happens and sometimes it's okay to lose
the pounds and then make the million now
what i mean by this is
is this like i've had situations where
i've bought a whole portfolio off of a
landlord i've bought like six or seven
houses
and i got a good deal overall but some
of the properties haven't performed too
well i've needed some cash flow
to put into some really good deals and
i've got the cash in the bank because
i've bought loads of houses my money's
tied up and then i'm like
geez i need to sell some houses but i
know
that if i sell some of these
underperforming houses
i'm going to be like that that's
terrible for me because i'm selling it
less than i paid for it but
my here's an analogy that one of my
mentors said to me and it just made me
think you know what
that is such a good analogy because i
used to i never used to do this i used
to always say
every single individual one of my houses
needs to make money and if it doesn't
i'm going to or not and i'm gonna hold
it until it goes up in value because out
of principle every single house
needs to make me money and what my
mentor said to me is he because he
advised me to sell some of my little
houses and he's i'll sell that one stuff
i can't sell that one for 50 grand i
bought it for 60 grand that's ridiculous
and what he said is he said the thing is
though you've got to sell a couple of
these houses because of the
the kings come along i'm like what do
you mean he said you're playing
property monopoly like you're playing
chess and
sometimes you've got a you've got to
sacrifice the pawn
to protect the king and if you've got a
property deal or you've got something
going on or a project and you've got
timelines on it or if you've got an
absolutely ridiculous
opportunity to buy something below
market value and you know you can fix it
up and refinance it and pull all your
money out and it's a beautiful project
and you know
but actually you haven't got the money
but you can get the money by selling off
a couple of these not so good houses
well you know what that's the king and
these are the pawns so
say goodbye to the pawns protect the
king because ultimately these pawns are
never going to make you rich anyway
the king's going to make you rich and i
just thought that's so true sometimes
we let principal and ego ego as well he
goes another thing
maybe i mean in my case i might have
bought property and i've told my friends
and family i've bought this house and
this is what i'm going to do with them
this is
and then it's like actually you know
what i want to sell this house now and
if i sell it now it's at a loss and
your ego can be so big that you think
i'm not prepared to do that
i'm going to sacrifice the king just to
not let people see my pawn go but you
know what i'd rather do i'm playing
chess
i'd rather let people go you know oh my
gosh your pawn went oh you're struggling
um
and then it's like yeah but i'm good i'm
still gonna beat you at chess
because i've got my kings and queens and
horses so that's
a way that i've lost money but sometimes
it's okay to lose money in those sort of
circumstances i hope you enjoyed this
video by the way if you're learning a
lot about property comment below comment
your thoughts below if you haven't
smashed the like button smash it right
now
number four have i lost money i have
lost
money big money
in auctions now when i say i've lost
money in auctions you might be thinking
oh well what you've probably done is
you've gone to an auction and you've got
wrapped up into an emotional bidding war
and you've paid too much
nope you might think oh you've lost
money in auction i know
maybe you have gone to an auction and
you've bid on a property and then you've
got to complete on it but you've not
done surveys and stuff and you end up
with a duff property
nope i would never do that because i'm
too advanced in property to do that
here's how i've lost money
in auction i've lost money in auction by
selling
properties in auction i'll tell you a
little story and i've kind of talked
about this a little bit on samuel 365 on
the coaching calls i've never spoken
about this on youtube
i'll tell you the story i'm still a
little bit resentful i'm still a little
bit wounded but it's okay
so before corona virus
before all that stuff i was selling some
of my houses and i was telling them to
put them into bigger deals
and i spoke to my auctioneer great great
guy okay he stood by me i've done
business with him in the past
great guy i really recommend him his
name's sam fongo
i'll probably get him on the channel at
some point and i was putting some houses
on for auction with sam fongo
and you know what i put when i was
setting the reserves i set the reserves
i said this is the minimum i'll go
and i was you know we had a conversation
i spoke to amanda my wife and we
and the idea was if we put them a little
bit lower we're going to get more
interest
and then we're going to get when we get
more interest we're going to get more
bidders
you know so we should let's set the
reserves absolutely low i mean you might
have seen some houses where they set the
reserve price by the way the reserve
price means when you're selling from
auction if you set the reserve price on
a house
for a pound what that means is if
someone bids on it like it's like buying
from
ebay if someone bids on it and offers to
buy it for a pound you've got to sell it
to them for a pound
now if they come and offer a hundred
thousand they've got to buy it for a
hundred thousand because that's auction
terms
now the advantage to putting your house
on for a pound is you're going to get
loads of interest it's going to make the
newspapers it's like oh my gosh this guy
put his house on for a pound
and everyone's going to come and then
they're going to all bids and then it
can because there's so much interest
it can end up actually getting a high a
higher result a higher
sale price than it would if you put it
on at the actual price now of course i
think that's a bit stupid putting on for
a pound but i did put the reserve price
uncomfortably low should we say
uncomfortably luck now goes to auction
the problem is the day it goes to
auction
the same day was the day after
lockdown was announced i'm just like oh
my goodness at this point this was the
second of
april when the first of april was when
locked out i was thinking this is some
kind of a sick joke
so i got my houses i got them low
everyone's scared i'm even saying on my
youtube videos you know buy low buy low
buy low buy low you know
don't pay if you're not embarrassed
don't offer and anyway one of these
good guys came along and the annoying
thing was this guy i'm not going to say
his name but he's actually one of my
students
he's on samuel 365. and he bid on my
house
on a couple actually there was a few i
sold a few more houses
at a low price and it stung me and do
you know what the really annoying thing
is
the really annoying thing is when i
pulled it from the auction on the second
of april i was like i don't want to sell
it from auction
i poured it from auction but then i i
pulled it from that auction but i didn't
write in
to the auctioneer to say pull it all
together i want to terminate my contract
and they automatically put it into the
next auction which was in
which was like literally just a few
weeks ago and the day before the auction
amanda says you know houses are going to
auction tomorrow i'm
like oh whoa well we need to we need to
stop that like
like i don't even necessarily want to
sell them anymore i mean i do
but not in auction really cheap so i
rang up the auction i was like dude i
want to i want to pull the houses from
the auction now he said you can't do
that you're in terms
i'm like okay i said can you just change
the reserve price thing can you hire it
he said you cannot change the reserve
price now
the auction the auction ends too much an
online auction but it ends tomorrow
so i said no problem so i'm now praying
that they don't sell an auction i'm like
please please please by the way
it wasn't ridiculous ridiculously low it
was just lower than i'd like now
meanwhile i've got people contacting me
like james armstrong and alistair saying
samuel you know honestly these houses
are decent little houses we'll buy them
off yeah we've got buyers
what's the reserve price i'm like 85 for
this little four bed hmm they're like
what's the
value i'm like the value is like 100
grand or more um
i'd easily sell it for 100 but the
reserve's 85. they're like well we'll
buy it for 95.
so i'm praying praying
that this houses don't sell at auction
guess what the auctioneer phones with
the next day says
samuel they've sold i'm like how much
how much how much
and there's that most of them sold at
the reserve price and i was just
so disappointed and i said that to him i
said i am so
disappointed he was ah i don't want you
to disappoint man you're a good customer
i felt like the auctioneer would almost
tip people off this is the reserve price
no they wouldn't do that okay they
wouldn't do that so i'm wounded by that
and i wanted to share that wound with
you i guess the lessons in it are number
one if you put a property on auction and
then you pull it make sure that when you
pull it from auction
you then follow up with a letter and
officially pull it make sure that
um the reserve price is a reserve price
that you're actually okay with
um because initially when i went in we
were talking about the reserve price
being a lot higher and then they're like
oh you know what for this auction we
could
you know so just be careful of that but
we live
we learn we grow ultimately i'm happy
because
because the money's going to very good
use and
throughout this whole period and looking
at some of my other houses like i can
[ __ ] and whine and moan about some of
the bad deals
i mean some of i wanted to sell a few
houses i was looking at them across the
board
i wanted to sell the houses where i'm
like you know what the capital
appreciation's been rubbish i bought
them a couple years ago or so and
nothing's really happening
and i want to i'll just sell them some
of my other houses have
performed with again it goes back to
underperformers performers and
overperformers
if you have a lot of houses you're
always going to have some that don't
perform and you are going to lose money
sometimes as annoying as it is so that
was my fault
i take full responsibility number five
this one is also my fault i take full
responsibility
i feel like i'm getting punched now
punched him out around by mike tyson
this is builders i've lost money in
property by
not dealing with builders properly
choosing them
wrongly managing them wrongly not having
the correct terms
and and stuff so i'm going to talk very
briefly about that firstly
when you're getting builders to do a
project my advice would be
find one building company company
don't find oh i'll get an electrician to
do the electrics and i'll get a plumber
to do the plumbing and i'll get a carpet
fit to do the carpets and i'll get a
plastic through the blaster and i'll
find a painting in the painting
don't do that because then you what
you'll do is you're gonna you're gonna
be a project manager of all these people
and they're gonna be bickering and
they're gonna be blaming each other it's
gonna be more expensive
just find a building company that will
do the lot
and the building company will also act
almost as a project manager as well
to to all the different workers they
won't get in each other's way they'll be
systemized
and it will probably believe it or not
end up cheaper for you that's the first
thing get a building company
don't get individual builders and if you
want to find a good building company
you need to just find builders on google
that have got good reviews that
promote themselves and say that they can
do things like extensions
maybe even building houses from scratch
if they can do bigger stuff like that
they're going to be able to do your full
refurb so that's the first thing second
thing is
make sure that you get with builders
because i've lost money doing this as
well
get an itemized breakdown of what
they're doing don't just get them to say
oh it'd be 20 grand to refurb the house
come again
and i've literally had this i've just
i've had builders that have said oh
they've looked around and we've
discussed what they're going to do and
then they said it'd be 20 grand pay me
10 grand now and then 10 grand upon
completion i've got no problem paid them
10 grand
but then the re what what they're doing
is not what we talked about
and then they'll start doing more and
say oh well we are going to need to
obviously do you know we're going to do
this this and this which we didn't talk
about on on the day
so that's going to be extra and this is
going to be extra that's going to be
extra it's like no that
but you charged me 20 grand for the full
refurb well yeah we charge you 20 grand
to do the
to do the main problems and the
structural stuff but the actual
this this and this that's not including
the quote and it's like oh okay well
either i'm an idiot or you're a liar or
something's up
and bottom line is you gotta take
responsibility i take full
responsibility this hasn't happened
recently this is more back in the day
but you need to get a quote and you need
to get a full breakdown an itemized
breakdown of every single job that
they're going to do and i would advise
also
not just having an itemized breakdown
but also how much each thing is going to
cost as well
so okay we're going to do the the
bathroom is going to going to be your
fix and that's going to be
2 000 pound and then we'll do the
kitchen and that's going to be this much
and also not just the bathroom the
kitchen what does that entail are you
going to get a new bath
are they going to do tiling are they
going to paint it once it's finished you
need
everything written down third thing is
you need to project manage them now you
don't need to be
necessarily full full-on with project
managing them either every day
but even if they're a building team and
it's a company you can't just go
anyway good luck 10 when you're finished
and then leave them you need
to have a whatsapp group you need to be
asking for regular pictures and updates
you need to be going down regularly
probably once a week but at least once a
month
and looking at it and seeing how they're
getting on and holding them
to account because it's human nature if
they're
effectively boss or employer or
whoever's giving them the job is not
ever there
and they're just on their own they're
not going to perform the same way and if
you can't be there because you're busy
then get someone to represent you and go
down
and oversee and make sure that the job
is getting done so
get time get time frames agreed
timelines in place
really important because this is
honestly if you're doing buy
refurbishing finance and development
the way that you're going to lose big
time in property often
is builders not managing them properly
not finding them properly not having the
correct contracts and guidelines in
place so anyway
that's my little painful depressing
rant over i hope you found this useful
though because you know what where i
might have lost out or lost money or
i've
you know put some on auction it's all
too cheap or i've had a bad experience
with the builders or
or i've just generally got a property
that's not performing well but that's
normal that's okay
so let me know what you think about this
video as well comment your thoughts
below
please do smash the like subscribe turn
the notification bell on
and i'll see you on the next video and
one more thing
if you want to see my worst ever house
you got to watch that right here
if you want to see students of mine that
have performed well in property and
learn from their mistakes and from their
successes
check that out right here and of course
you can subscribe down here below
subscribe and i'll see you next time